on 9/11 my mom worked in downtown
Manhattan in the second building that
was hit survived was fine but I didn't
know I was like oh my mom's dead and I
started to cry and this guy Frank
started laughing at me and I immediately
just broke a chair over his head and I
got expelled from the school on 911 so I
called my dad and I was like Hey Dad I
got expelled from the school and he goes
I'm coming down there I'm going to
negotiate with the principal brother Rob
my dad goes let's figure out another way
and then brother Rob says sir are you
stupid there's no other way and my dad
goes you just call me stupid he goes
Chrissy lock the door so I shut the door
and he goes listen you have two options
here's the first option just let my son
back in school here's the second option
I'm going to come over there and I'm
going to break both of your kneecaps I'd
rather go back to prison for the rest of
my life and be with my friends then you
throw him out and me have to listen to
his mother's mouth for the rest of my
life he goes so the choice is yours it's
up to you and then brother Rob's like
okay well then he's back